et on a le plaisir de recevoir aussi
ceux qui étaient dans ma singer les
frères bogdanoff
merci d'être là il dort grillage et on
était sûr que c'était mutation à douille
ouais franchement dès l'été ou bataille
et fontaine où on s'est dit ce sera les
travaux est-ce que vous avez quitté
l'aventuré
oui oui tout à fait là vraiment on s'est
amusé quand il a été arrêté pour rigoler
et en fait pendant toute l'émission
c'est on s'est vraiment amusé d'abord
d'abord il faut dire que quand tu es en
studio et que tu que tu es amené à
produire de la musique équipe et on
essaie de faire de la vraie musique bien
sûr donc du coup ça ça nous a amusé
parce que ça ça résonne avec notre côté
musiciens comment alors je vous étiez
les cherry hill rendu cramer de
l'émission rayonne dès le début rien
qu'avec les ondes les indices mais on
savait tous que c'était les frères bob
bonjour à tous nous sommes ravis quand
on chante sur scène ou à la télé on ne
sent pas qu'en français il faut savoir
s'ouvrir à l'international
rien n'est loin dans le temps la musique
comme les modes tout est cyclique
parce qu'à dunkerque vous les connaissez
c'est sûr on est là et monte partout
fortement remaniée au début on était
rarement l'un sans l'autre à la télé sur
les plateaux dans les émissions dans les
journaux on était à 2 faut dire qu'on a
bien vu que c'est ce qui amuse les gens
eh ouais voyez pas on est loin des
crânes de piaf
même si on est un peu des têtes de bois
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas c'est pas trop chaud dans les
costumes horrible du point de vue pas
seulement de la chaleur mais surtout on
ne voit rien dire qu'on a l'impression
de voeux un sous marin on a juste deux
meurtrières qui permettent de regarder
jamais devant mais c'est vraiment ça et
donc on est un petit peu comme les cds
des êtres très étrange c'est vrai que
les perroquets sont déjà étrange en soi
mais là se déplacer avec ses costumes
c'est déjà une performance donc une
émission très sportive vous avez dit oui
tout de suite pour l'émission ah oui
sans hésiter parce qu'en fond quand on
nous a proposé de chanter et d'être
costumé donc en les contrant savais pas
que c'était des perroquets au départ on
s'est dit tiens pourquoi pas alex
intéressant mais aussi mais là on nous a
dit madame on a là un peu trop et donc
du coup c'est vrai qu'on a maintenant on
n'a pas hésité on était on était ravi de
faire ça non mais alors et il paraît je
vous pose la question il paraît que vous
êtes payé pareil que vous restiez tous
les émissions ou une fois c'est un
candidat il a fait que manas a manié
donc on a fait ressortir vite parce
qu'en fait tu payé pareil
en fait pour nous évidemment on divise
par deux en plus donc quand vous avez
pas dit ouais même passé non c'était
très symbolique pour nous on fait pas
vraiment oui si les planètes
là nous on est encore sur terre là dans
les intérieurs combien je me permets de
vous poser la question comme vous êtes
des amis en toute transparence je dirais
comme on les aime beaucoup m'a pas dit
que c'était symbolique pour vous on m'a
donné une somme vous allez dire si c'est
vrai de 40000 euros chacun pour la
participation aux faits 80000 symbole
non tu peut la diviser par deux déjà
assez vain vie de chacun mais oui
d'accord et avec 40000 8 mai pour une
belle somme
c'est une bonne info de salon c'est
aussi parce qu'ils avaient envie de
chanter les béjaouis vous êtes découvert
patients ont pris dans une même envie de
chanter maintenant après bac d'abord
d'un oeuf
on va voir la révélation bien sûr tout
le monde était sûr qu'il s'agissait des
bogdanoff alors qu'en fait bas il
s'agissait des baux
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour m
regardez dans l'humour
c'est ça ce héros
[Musique]
celui qui va se démasquer ce soir
mais rockets
et si la france et tous plantés à
allez
attention ces vingt ans
au bassinet
incroyable histoire est plus
qu'abordable c'est
[Applaudissements]
sa patrie et ses coûts et toi tu étais
vraiment le premier à dire tout de suite
c'est évidemment pense qu'avant tout le
temps dans des convois de personnes je
crois que c'est vous les banques alors
niveau chaud ça pas trop progressé en
plus premier épisode la semaine dernière
un week-end ou non vous disiez que vont
soir vous disais que vous étiez
intéressé de faire cette émission par
rapport à la musique mais je ne vois pas
ce qui est intéressant par rapport à la
musique étant donné que ces vocodée on
reconnaît pas votre voix enfin l'or
alors qu'on est un peu mais c'est très
pratique et et en plus de ça c'était
enregistré en avant en amont en amont
donc serais je comprends pas c'est que
sur le plateau vous n'êtes pas en direct
dont je vois pas ce qui m'intéresse dans
la musique ce type me permettre aux
récits plus bas mais en fait c'est oui
c'est l'invention de ce nouveau type de
rapport effectivement à la musique qui
est complètement bloquée pote pas
vraiment vocodée c'est qu'en réalité
quand on est la première fois quand on
passe pour la répétition c'est un fait
complètement à vos côtés pour la
répétition pour que personne ne
reconnaît donc c'est un tunnel personne
non identifiée
en revanche quand on est sur scène pour
la prestation elle même
il n'y a pas de mot nage pas du tout
c'est vraiment d'ailleurs on dit
d'ailleurs que nous endetter on avait
connu les voix des gorilles h 15 pour
une petit grand devin ses doigts alors
une chose est sûre que c'est que ni vos
chances a pas énormément progressé
depuis le premier épisode
regardons regarder clairement mais on
n'est pas dans vos rues étroites et bon
cap
mais je ne sens pas la burqa
entre mouy un fort si droitier pour
passer la main
[Musique]
moi d'une aussi ici l'écrire ayo d'ici
bamba
[Musique]
oui
ils offriront musique ce que nous allons
faire un petit peu de flamenco
maintenant mais je reviens sur ce cas ni
qui vous enregistrez quand même les
prestations avancé oui bien sûr parce
que bon on peut pas chanter avec ce
masque sa capsule l'on retient peu cycle
j'ai en fait non techniquement oui
encore un accord très bien et ma passion
donc c'est vraiment content et en corée
c'est une corée pour ce qui nous
concerne